okay I'm I'm the rotating GM Grandmaster
Ben Feingold I used to be the only
Grandmaster residents but now I'm not
next week we'll have yes or Sarah won
back for about six weeks give or take
and I'll be here until Sunday Super Bowl
Sunday soon as the Super Bowl starts I'm
out okay well before we start the
lecture even though it's already started
that was an interesting sentence
grandmaster died a few days ago and got
none of you heard of him
well you heard of him at home and ken
was barely heard of him his name was
Gilles Sachs
he was a Hungarian Grandmaster he was a
candidate for the World Championship and
he was a very strong player when I lived
in Europe 25 years ago he was one of the
top 20 players in the world possibly top
10 in the world that's stretching it a
little but definitely top 20 so he was
one of the top five or six players in
Hungary for 30 years and while he died
last week yeah it seems like every week
when I lecture don't lecture a
grandmaster dies so I guess I'll be the
best player in the world soon might
might take two or three years but if I'm
alive I'm looking good
and for the intermediate lecture I'm
going to make things a little easier
than usual because normally when I ask
questions you know these these thought
bubbles above your heads with like you
know a donkey and flies around it and
you know like and there's just you know
there's like table Rosses everywhere you
know what I'm saying right man yeah he's
like man that's I took the words out of
his mouth okay so the first so I want to
show you some lighter games it's
interesting I won rated game on Friday
I played one Saturday I played one
Sunday the Chess Club was closed on
Monday so I played six No and that play
zero and then on Tuesday which was
yesterday I played two rated games in
the latter tournament and I won them
both surprisingly so I was black in the
first game and in the second game okay
so I'm playing everybody's favorite a
grandmaster beater
that's Preston Smith and Preston beat
Grand Master last month which is on our
website
st. Louis Chess Club org and a
simultaneous exhibition a perfect game
and that was the Grand Master residence
Josh free Dell the only geuman residence
who was a GM and residents less than
than this tenure this is a nine day ten
year that I have now I think he was like
four days so laughter luzina Preston no
matter how bad the weather was and how
many flights were canceled he had to fly
back to Milwaukee okay so I'm black
against Preston Preston always plays e4
and I play different openings I like to
play the caro-kann I've been talking
about the Carrick on lately with several
people and Preston played theory for at
least three moves which is almost a
record okay almost okay I'll have to
look into that but there are stats
Department analyzed that okay he played
the advanced variation now Preston likes
to play F for when he's Wyatt and I'm
from Michigan and there's a player there
named Jennifer Skidmore who's a Class A
player and she also always plays f4 with
white and every opening doesn't played
on move one but she plays that for
eventually so every move I'm waiting for
f4 like okay where's that for it's
already move three come on okay now as
you know this is called the advanced
variation of the Carroll Khan and what
is the main move that black can play in
this position anyone anyone you this
ship f5 now if you know me I don't like
to play the main move because my
opponent is more likely to know the main
move the Noah sideline now this you may
not know which move for black is the
most common that is not the ship f5 ah
there's the horse of a different color
yes Dorothy c5 is correct he didn't get
the The Wizard of Oz reference but even
so in the horse of a different color all
right Ken Weiss thank you okay all now
they get now that I explain it okay good
so c5 now this looks like an advanced
French except my pawn is not on e6 come
on work
it's green ooh now it's red cool okay
and then I like colors so normally your
pawns on e6 well that didn't work and
this is an advanced French but I've
played c6 and c5 so I'm down a tempo but
I haven't played e6 yet so when I play
Bishop to f5 oh let's do it in red okay
then my bishop will be outside of the
pawn chain usually that Bishop has some
issues now the way to punish c6 and c5
is to take on c5 so grandmasters would
take on c5 here and whites upon ahead
black eventually wins his pawn back but
white has sort of a good version of the
advanced French I think okay but Preston
probably didn't know that move c5 he
played a move that I faced a lot which
is c3 and whites still playing like in
the advanced French mode except I'm
going to have a nice Bishop on f5 okay
now this is a move a lot of players like
you guys and you at home would play
Preston plays it a lot against me in
similar positions and it's almost always
a mistake so hopefully Preston's not
watching this okay a very common mistake
that I see a lot fact the week before I
be Preston in a ladder game where he
blundered upon I move five the same way
he plays Bishop to b5 he likes playing
Bishop b5 but that's something that you
should not like because with all of your
pawns on dark squares your dark square
Bishop is sort of locked behind them but
your white square bishop is pretty
awesome and it's considered your good
Bishop so you don't want to trade it for
my knight although he always does that
so this opening seems to work out for me
and when I played the French defense he
plays the advance and we do the same
thing and then I have the white square
bishop and he doesn't so there should be
five is a strategical error you you want
your Bishop on d3 if possible okay and
then you know you can sacrifice on h7
and mate your opponent likely not too
likely Penzer your playing but this show
goes on e 2 or D 3 in this kind of
position not on b5 where can be traded
now
I had fond memories many
years ago I won this bishop so I played
Bishop f5 and what ended up happening
was in this other game from from years
ago although I'm this actually didn't
happen and I'm making it up but okay
we're just making we're just inventing
moves now now in a position like this I
was playing a player rated 1500 plus tax
now he wasn't as good as the Missouri
1500 player because tax is less in
Michigan so you guys got like nine or
ten percent or some fraction I can't
understand and in Michigan just six and
when I was a kid tax was four percent of
Michigan so the players were even weaker
okay well I played Bishop takes b1 now
who can raise their hand as I get my hot
chocolate and tell me the right move for
white what's the right move here for
Wyatt ken west that's not raising your
hand
that's not raising your hand now let's
call on a random student ken west what
should white play also wait a minute you
were sitting in the back what happened
you got her early to sit in the back
Ken's like I can see it's too far
Queen a four that's actually very
interesting hmm
Queen a for Queen a four is much better
than what my opponent did so I'm glad I
wasn't playing you that Queen a four
might be the right answer okay well what
white should play Bishop takes Knight on
c6 and then take the bishop on b1
possibly ken Wesley was even better
possibly I don't say probably because
you know by the fear you know by Occam's
razor and Bayes theorem it can't be
right
anyway rook takes b1 was played by my
opponent very suspicious okay that's the
one I expected him to play and then I
want a free bishop if you're taking
notes winning a free bishop is good okay
anyone who can who can bend do you know
you're just a pretty face you just work
here what no do you know
sir he's like chess I'm just standing
here
leave me alone no no Malvina what do you
do you can do it
how does out is black with a piece
probably this piece as it's hanging
correct Czech Bishop b4 check now now
just kidding correct Queen a5 check is
what I played or well I didn't do that
okay I had a little little little too
much today so okay and then it was me
because the King can't go to f1 because
of the other arrow oh man that was an
awesome move hold on let me let me
protect that square further okay right
and then all me and look how the king is
trapped terrible okay
so then my opponent actually resigned I
believe okay so I was hoping to do
something like this with Preston but
Preston played Bishop takes c6 check and
I played the best to move because I'm
the grand master in residence
so I played be take c6 and we developed
our pieces okay and Preston played
Bishop III and we need to pause here
because whenever somebody moves a bishop
I have to give a chess lesson and I've
said the same thing many times someday
somebody will listen now I'm just nobody
will ever listen when you move your
Bishop you're unde offending the pawn on
the second rank that your Bishop was
protecting okay I don't have a pawn on
b7 so I can move my bishop okay
even though happen later okay so the
pawn on b2 is now unprotected also the
pawn on g2 but that's hard to attack
Bishop h3 is risky only Shroff can play
such moves anyone anybody got that even
and I terrible okay one of the greatest
Bishop endings of all time was a game
Chirag where he played Bishop h3 and it
was hanging and then he wins by one
tempo because I'm all right but look
look the game up you'll like it
okay so I want to attack b2 because his
Bishop isn't defending b2 and it's not
an open wine so make sense I should want
to attack it on the other hand my pawn
on c5 is attacked and it's in green so
that's that be careful
okay so what move can I make to defend
my c5 pawn and attack is b2 one two four
one who can do it probably can attack
net beat Suppan and defend the c5 pawn
all in one move or double your money
back for this lecture Queen to b6 okay
now he didn't want me to play Queen
takes b2 because then I'd probably win
so he played Queen to d2 and now I
realized that his queen on g2 was
blocking all of his pieces
neither Knight can go to GT soon as
Bishop can't go to d2 and more
importantly his King can't go to d2 no
that's not that important okay and
because of that I can play a typical
caro-kann move that you normally don't
see in the French but this start is a
carro con so it's still a carro con and
what you want to do in the French
advance when this Bishop is on CA is you
very often play Knight g7 Knight f5 the
reason you do that is Knight f6 is too
risky play Knight f6 you can get in
trouble but you can play 97 to f5 okay
when you play Bishop f5 in the Carroll
con it's hard to play Knight f5 because
your bishops there so I play typical
caro-kann move which I first saw in a
game played around 1990 between Nigel
short and yes or Sarah one yes you'll be
here next week we can ask them if I got
the year right and yassir played Bishop
to e4 his knight was already on e7 he
wanted to play Knight to f5 and now
there should be for his extra strong
because I don't know what he's going to
do about his Knight there I'm going to
take it and ruin his pawn structure and
if he moves I'm going to take on g2 and
9 h4 like smells because I think it's
ammonia ammonium nh4+ yeah I don't know
it's one of them ok however the
highest-rated chemists in the world is
anyone anyone know you guys don't know
he's a professor at Dartmouth named
David Glick I hope you're watching this
he's 2400 player quit chess and became a
chemistry professor so I should actually
email him and say as an NH for a h3 ok
so well White's position he's in a lot
of trouble here because I'm going to
mess up his pawns now
you didn't want to mess up just one set
of pawns where you can mess up too if
you saw the terrible movie contact
you'll get that joke and no nobody saw
that movie so now you saw it
yeah he's white builds one when you
could build two that made a lot of sense
okay also man see Makani in them we made
a lot of sense
all right anyway he played Knights a
three very suspicious okay well that was
the only legal night move you got to
give him that and he didn't want a cast
though because I'm going to take on that
three so he's sort of stuck maybe he
should have played queen - II - hmm
anyway I started to take things because
that seems like a good idea
Grandmaster Ken West you have three
pieces that can take on d4 it's true
which one would you capture with reverse
psychology over here anyone at home have
an answer you're shaking your head at
home what's that with a pawn okay
now taking what the pawn is risky yeah
it's risky because Bishop b4 gives black
a slight advantage yeah that's why it's
risky okay now we know why the GM is in
quotes okay so my opponent didn't like
that although I would have known
let's see another some percent he's
going to play it okay but he played
Bishop takes d4 attacking my queen but I
saw it so I played c5 he played the only
move remember I wanted to play Knight to
f5 so we got to start with 90 to e7 okay
now one of the reasons you guys are in
very good at chess is you don't know how
to chill right even now like Julian's
twirling upon he shake it in his chair
right he has to go to the bathroom but
he's like I'll miss the lecture so he's
all confused okay and the higher rated
players like Ronin Harvey he's so
Chili's not even here like he's like I
he's relaxing at home you know okay so
you got to be calm and slowly improve
your position that's not Preston's mo
most low rated players don't calmly
improve their position
they lash out violently my commerce
style okay so what's the most violently
lashing out move that white can play and
that's what he played b4 now the problem
is you won't see White's position in
pawn structure chess because he has the
seven-week pawns and hilary's doesn't
have a tweak pawns is because the only
has seven pawns even the pawn off the
board was like shaking a bit like all
right you know like jumping off the
table trying to escape okay so my C pawn
is attacked and I want it to play Knight
f5 so that was sort of nice my bishop
protects now this fun structure isn't
bad enough so let's make it worse okay
and that's that's about as bad a pawn
structures you can have I think I don't
think there's a worse pawn structure
possible although my next game may prove
that wrong
which was play the same day so hard
understand actually now my pawn
structure is pretty good I got five
pawns one pawn island White has nine
pawn islands hard to understand that
possibly I'm wrong possibly okay and he
played nine to c2 since his Knights
attacked and I castled now I was
expecting Knight to d4 and then if I
take his a knight he can straighten out
all of his pawns if I don't take his
knight he might take my knight and ruin
my pawns
so I was thinking whom what do I do
against Knight d4 but preston was pretty
quickly and we're playing gaben 30 so
we'd have a lot of time to think then
you played 93 and the 93 does not defend
the f3 pawn which the knight on d4 does
so I attacked it who would like to
suggest we won't pick on Ken this time
I'll pick on whoever answers who would
like to suggest a way for white to stop
knight takes f3 check yes sir
King e2 was played I actually don't see
another good way of doing it if you if
you move your queen you know to defend
the pawn you're sort of leaving this
pawn hanging and then your rooks and
then it's all hanging your ePHI pawn
so I don't really see a good way to and
this is why doubled pawns and isolated
pawns are bad because other pawns can't
protect them and if you look at my pawn
chain here everybody could be protected
and even the ones that aren't protected
by other pawns they could be I could
play h6 and this protects this or I
could play g6 and to upon's protect it
so even if my pawns aren't protected by
other pawns it's possible they'll be
protected here white just loses all of
his pawns it's the worst fun structure
ever until the next game so he lasted
one game ok now you have many great
suggestions yes well I could but I
wouldn't call that a threat I would call
that taking a winning advantage and
giving myself an advantage because if I
play Queen takes tonight
it totally straightens out his pawn
structure I went upon right yeah and
then it's a deaden game and I got want
to pawn up somehow
probably I'd lose no I'd probably win ok
so Julian has a crazy idea because you
know is he's not 2300 yet he said after
94 I should still play this white will
make a Nothing move so that the
variation works and then I sacrificed my
queen and then I went back my queen and
blacks a pawn up and should win I
somewhat agree but I think this is
better for white than the actual than
not doing that because now he has fewer
weak pawns because I took them ok and
you know he's a pawn down but it's hard
for me to win probably should win so
that's a tricky way of getting rid of
his weak pawns of winning upon I don't
know what I would have done but it would
have been something I could have
lectured about but left to wait till
next time okay but 94 clearly a superior
move because now there's nothing you can
do look at all those arrows and colors
what could you do
okay say play King e2 as suggested by
Julian notice how his King is defending
his F pawn did you notice that and
there's something you learned earlier in
your life called removing the defender
so what's defending is F pawn is king so
I played removing the defender
how did I remove that King I just picked
it up now I didn't do that Queen to be
five now while he moves this king
I removed the defender you can't argue
with that and if he blocks with his
Queen which he did not do I take his
queen he takes back I take this and now
he's got to defend a five good luck and
he's down upon and somehow he has five
isolated pawns although not really but
it seems like he has 500 point five
isolated pawns wait till next game okay
not kidding okay
and I think Knight g4 just loses to h5 I
think
okay so horrible so you didn't play
Queen d3 he played well King IPF won the
Knight takes pawn check attacking his
queen
now King f1 was suggested by men and
Justin because they don't make legal
moves too often okay now they made
mostly legal moves I'm just kidding okay
so he played c4 and I took and now c3
check would win more material Queen
takes e5 wins material so he played
Queen c3 and again I want to attack the
f3 pawn so I played Queen c6 attacking
the f3 pawn okay and I have two guys
attacking it this one and this all I
guess this is actually a girl I have one
guy attacking okay now if you want to
defend your pawn you have to move your
knight then your queen defend sideways
you could play Knight takes e4 which is
very dangerous because I could pick your
night with rook c8 but probably I would
just take anyway then this looks like
White's not having a lot of fun
White's down upon and his King is a bit
iffy his works are pretty active no not
really
so although that's better than what
happened so okay so Knight takes e4 is
probably the right move but he played
Knight to g4 and now black wins in one
move somehow the game continued but I
went in one move now I'm attacking f3 he
defended f3 but
now I have a move that really crushes
him h5s you're in the wrong class now
the night does not have a plethora of
squares you said that often don't you
yeah so then I can go to h6 or f6 he did
go to one of those squares or he could
not move and I would take a night which
is good where he'd go back to e3 and
then I would take on f3 and it would be
horrible for him not for me be great for
me
so after h5 things aren't looking very
good so if two grandmasters were playing
white would resign because if you make
any move it gets going to be really bad
like then up on down okay but now now
it's like seriously bad and well
whenever my opponent moves their pieces
near me and I can attack them
I see if they have retreat squares or he
can save there but he can't so h5 is
sort of a strange move because I've
canceled but I'm threatening a peace
that has nowhere to go
one of the mistakes you guys make a lot
especially Julian is you attack pieces
and they can move to like ten different
squares and I'm like why'd you do that
you're like oh I tacked his piece and
I'm like well he moved it away how'd
that help now here it helps because he
can't move it away so that's even better
you can attack a piece that can't move
away that you're going to capture it so
93 which he did not play would allow
Queen takes f3 check or night x f3 and
then I don't know who wants to play
white here but it's not me I refused to
make a move for Wyatt even if you
suggested probably like you'd suggest a
good move because the illegal move is
looking good now so you know Queen takes
e4 Queen takes e4 attacks the knight and
the Queen King takes f3 even better now
there's the king of illegal moves so
okay my opponent played the aggressive
Knight f6 check which I took then he
checked me again man 2 checks in a row
then I went back and he took this now
some of you may have noticed my rooks
aren't very active but you were sort of
quiet about it thank you okay so I
played rook to d8 and now he made a
threat which
very nice because I am up a piece so you
know you should make any threats Queen C
- somebody raise their hand and tell me
what white is threatening white just
played Queen C - that's a hint C White's
last move Queen C - yeah
so what's white threatening yes you know
the answer I can tell rip takes g6 with
a monster attack okay although it's not
working yeah there we go
okay and then if it's queen goes to g6 I
could get in trouble I don't want his
queen to go to g6 now yesterday somebody
we won't name they said check me but it
wasn't checkmate because their opponent
could block the check and this blocking
thing seems to be an issue with a lot of
you you guys know how to move on it
check now how to block if your opponents
threatening something you can protect it
you could ignore it because you don't
see it all so that would be tomorrow's
class at 7:00 or you could block how do
I block the Queen from going to g6
Grandmaster yet block the Queen from
going to the g6 square how do I do that
how does black do that very Grandmaster
like in presentation Thank You rook to
d3
now I'm threatening Queen f3 which gives
me the advantage and I'm stopping him
from going to g6 now in this position my
opponent did not notice f3 was attacked
and he was going to play rook to g5 and
when his Rick was on g5 with his hand
over it he was like he saw f3 was
hanging put the Rick back on g1 and
wondered where can I move this rook to
defend my f3 pawn again most
grandmasters would think differently
they would think I'm resigning now but
ok ok so he played rook to g3 which
makes a lot of sense and was very upset
when I made the right move he's like ah
like he knew I would find that but he's
like ah if I'd only played another move
then he'd have a chance
yeah so what is the move that's really
crushing here extra crushing plus tax
it's very similar to h5 very similar
this sort of looks like h5 yeah and I'm
not kidding serious
you H more now your works doing double
duty here it spinning my night but it's
defending f3 and that's the only square
can do it from so if your whip goes
vertically I will take on f3 if your
whip goes horizontal ergo h3 that Knight
f4 check is good for black because my
Knights not pinned anymore and I take
his rook so he didn't like when I played
h4 so he played the best move I think
rook takes g6 and I recaptured now I'm
up a rook so I'm looking good and I
never noticed until right now he has
triple pawns ah ok so even solicit bad
pawn structure rook g'wan Queen f3 King
e1
now I tried to play the computer move
here most humans would defend g6 and
then then the game would be over like
you know king f7 ok but I was like well
I don't think that pawn matters very
much
so I played rook to d8 threatening rook
d1 with me he put me in check and I
moved my king now playing white is
difficult because rook d1 is me and I
guess like I show the skin to my son
Spencer he's like rook g8 the computer
moved best and I was like yeah then if I
take it f7 check best also true but ok
instead my opponent resigned so in that
game I castled and he didn't and I sort
of dominated the center but most
importantly I had a really good pawn
structure his pawn structure was a bit
iffy in fact and a lot of openings
called the advanced variation Carroll
Khan French white gets more space but
White's pawn structure can get a little
iffy because he's moving all his pawns
up and then I take them ok a my pawn
sort of stay back and well the pawn
structure changed a bit when I started
taking his pieces then the pawn
structure doesn't matter anymore
ok the next game was very similar except
black had an even worse pawn structure
or white did probably black did too ok
so why had a much worse pawn structure
in this game but when he did it was in
tensional because he had other
advantages but he didn't take advantage
of those advantages ok great sentence
okay so I plays a Carol con I'm playing
Justin Hall everybody's favorite 17 a
1600 player ah supposed to be funny
okay because I would have been right
about two months ago all right 9c3 now
I've played just too many blitz games
and when I play d5 here it always plays
Queen f3 and he told me after the game
he was not going to play Queen f3 zijn
to play Knight f3 now I could prepare
for him for hours okay but I play d5 I
like playing c6 then he 5 confusing my
opponent Justin moved instantly d4 he
was not perturbed now I had a game with
Nolan Hendrickson a few months ago where
he played d3 and then d 4 and I took it
he took with a queen and even then white
was better so I was like man if I take
on d4 now that's a tempo down so I
played d6 and we traded everything and
this is sort of like a Philidor where
white trades Queens early which I've had
with white and black King he ate f6
Bishop e3 and I decided to try to ruin
his pawns with Bishop b4 and Justins
like that's fine so I did and now blacks
development is a bit suspicious a bit ok
but I have a good pun structure so the
game went from really boring when we
traded Queens to really double-edged
either he's going to crush me with his
lead and development into bishops or
he's going to have the worst pawn
structure ever hopefully the ladder
which ended up happening
so I played b6 because I wanted at some
point to play King e7 and Bishop e6 and
trade the bishops but kingi 7 runs into
Bishop c5 check also maybe I'll play
Bishop a6 and trade bishops if I can
trade trade trade trade trade that his
pawn structure is pretty bad but if I
don't trade that he might checkmate me
and attacked with his bishops so I want
pieces off the board because I have the
better pawn structure
now after b6 White has a very obvious
plan which might
and didn't think of so I won the game
but every move white should play this
plan the next ten moves white should be
doing this but since he didn't think
about it he didn't do it that's a good
excuse
can't argue with that if you thought
about it and didn't do it that's
different then I would have said well
you should have done it you thought
about it here he's like on me I didn't
see that idea so what's the main idea
that white should play in this position
it's very similar to when I played h5h
four against Preston except not White's
doing it so what's the winning plan for
white anyone Bueller they went at home
now you guys don't know either what we
think offer what he got over here Justin
told you but you remembered
that's impressive it was a whole day ago
yeah you should play a four a five okay
and then he soughing me up on the b6
square he's opening a file for his rook
and it's he's getting rid of an isolated
point even if white wasn't attacking
white should do that anyway white has a
terrible isolated pawn and he's trading
it off so after a four I don't know what
I should do I can't play a five and stop
him because my b6 pawn is hanging just
takes it if I don't play a five that
he's going to play a five so probably
I'm going to let him play a five and
I'll play B five when the moments right
then he'll move his bishop and place 4
and his dark square bishop is really
good and we want to talk about that also
when you have two bishops which White
has White has two bishops okay if you're
playing bughouse you could have three or
four bishops but in regular chess you
could have two bishops black does not
have two bishops which is intentional I
mess up his pawn structure but I give
him two bishops now in this situation my
opponent has a dark square bishop and I
don't and we both have white squared
bishops in this instance he wants his
dark squared bishop to crush me because
I can't compete with it when I play b6
he should be playing a four a five
accentuating the strength of his dark
squared bishop now it's hard to play a
four a five you didn't think of it then
how you going to play it now there's a
game I played with Papa blot knee from
2002 in the world open in Philadelphia
and I had a similar pun structure with
white and I played a four a five and
eventually I won the game in a thousand
moves and the game actually went to the
New York Times it was one of the few
games I won that they printed usually I
have to lose and then it goes right in
there okay
even before I lose like the editors are
there did he resign did he resign I
never mind click and they put it anyway
they just write that I resigned ok but
ok I won this game and I played a four a
five trade off my isolated point this
font is isolated in week and there's
just nothing black can do a four a five
black white wants to trade it off or
make it a strong pawn and it really
makes the bishop on III much stronger
against my my crushing pawn chain there
well he didn't think of that
he played Rick fe1 and I thought he
played Rick fe1 for a very particular
reason but he was like now so I thought
that he thought that I wanted to play
Bishop a6 which is true and then he
can't move his bishop away because his
rook is hanging so I thought he played
here rook F e1 and if I play Bishop a6
which I thought about then he would play
Bishop to b3 and I can't take his rook
on f1 but he was like mad just thought
that rook was good on e1 you instead of
that use your words
instead of what
right he what he said he wanted his rook
on e 1 which I don't I don't know I
don't want my rook anyone there's like a
bishop and a pawn in front of it so I
agree D 1 is a better square also I
would always play rook F 2 D 1 because I
want to play a 4 a 5 he didn't want to
play a 4 a 5 so he was gonna play rook a
to D 1 so that's sort of explains why he
played rook Fe 1 ok I played 97 and he
played Knight 2 D 2 which I perfectly
understand if the knight can go to C 4
and then I can go to d6 very reasonable
okay now again I wanted to play King e7
and Bishop here and trade the bishops so
I played Knight to g6 getting out of the
way of my king my opponent played g3
which stops Knight f4 and prepares f4
but this is the wrong plan a4 a5 is the
right plan and you have to realize if we
both do nothing for the next 10 moves
and as you know I'm the king of doing
nothing well then his pawn structure is
going to lose the game for him but if he
can checkmate my King in the center and
use the fact that his pieces are out and
mine art then he could get an advantage
that way and I think a 4 a 5 is the only
way to do this but he played f4 and I
was like ok let's get our rook out and
he played f5 now here I have went to
this game with a computer yet I suspect
the computer is not going to like my
move but I have an affinity for the move
Knight h8 I play nun h8 a lot that's why
I'm here lecturing and other
grandmasters are playing in Grandmaster
tournaments because I like to play 9 h8
but ok so I played 9 h8 because I'm
going to go to f7 and then to d6 and I
was like ok Knight d6 is a good square
and then my other night can go to
different squares I don't know maybe it
actually made more sense to play Knight
FA 97 night a six-night c5 the Knights
protect each other maybe that made more
sense I don't know but I like 9 h8 so I
got a chance to play it ok
so you probably don't like that eh eh he
played rook a z1 and I was very happy
because now I'm not worried about 8485
anymore and if he doesn't play a 4 a 5 I
think he's going to have weak queenside
pawns for the next well until the game
ends game didn't go 20 more moves but if
it did they would have been a week
Bishop a 6
does white want to trade bishops anyone
no white wants to keep all the pieces on
the board and attack my stupid King in
the center ok but my kids not as stupid
as you think okay two years of Community
College okay had some rough time but
okay it's trying all right
so Bishop e6 looks good okay it's like
inter Kournikova looks good but he's not
going to win okay and then 9 to d7
I finally got my pieces developed and
the piece that's not developed is on my
favourite square ok 9 88 97 was played
Knight f3 after the game I said why did
you play Knight f3 he said my night was
good on f3 that answer my question
although I don't see why he would think
that can't go to d4 can't go to e5 can't
go to g5 going h4 seems odd and if you
remember a few moves ago about saying
you do but if you remember a few moves
ago his Knight was on f3 D 1 to D 2 so I
don't know I thought that I was going to
d2 as we go to c4 and really crush me
now I did actually think of a reason why
he played Knight f3 but he said not
asked that why I did it
I thought if I move my knight away from
at d7 you know like 9 f8 that he would
play Knight takes e5 I would take and
then Bishop g5 check I thought that was
his plan and I was like he my Kings out
he said my rooks on d8 I got to watch
out for that tom so I played Knight f7
and now he shocked me
ok Peter Gabriel was asked to comment
and he played Bishop takes f7 which I
was not expecting
I thought he sort of liked his bishop on
e6 ok but he was pawn grabbing he wanted
to win a pawn
he went upon good for him if he does
nothing I'll play 96 and then I'll play
9f8 and this is attacked my night has c4
and he still has these weak pawns so
probably in this position a computer
would say blacks better
I'm guessing earlier in the game it's
going to say black was worse because
it's going to somehow attack me one of
the things I was worried about for the
last several moves was Bishop c1 Bishop
a3 check and he was like nod and look at
that so I was worried about a lot of
stuff but it didn't happen and the stuff
I wasn't worried about trading pieces
that did happen now he played rook to d6
and I thought I had many good moves but
the more I looked and where I didn't
like it my pawn is attacked and if I
play King g7 he can just check me away
if I defend my pawn he'll double his
rooks on the on the D file and my knight
is pinned and it's sort of hard to
defend it it's hard to break the pin so
I played Knight f8 not my Knights not
pinned seriously and he took upon yeah
he's a pawn ahead and I was thinking man
I want to win that rook because the rook
has nowhere to go so the rook can go to
c7 so I thought okay I'll play rip to d7
and then I'll play Bishop e5 and then
I'll take his rook if only things were
that easy but when he stops Bishop b5
let's say a four I don't see how attack
is rook my King can't attack it my
knight can't attack it if my bishop
attacks is Rucka gives them an escape
square and I could keep attacking it but
I don't think I want to draw or if white
wants to play for a win you could go
here so I really wanted to trap his rook
but I couldn't see a good way of doing
it so I just traded the rook off rook c8
and now White's upon a head but why it's
probably losing because all of these
pawns are really weak and I'm going to
take all of them and then some I'll take
some other pawns too while I'm at it
ah
I don't know what to tell you I would be
really unhappy with white here first of
all there's one way to defend your c3
pawn and he plied it and now I play rook
c4 and I have very simple plan I'm going
to play Bishop b7 and take your pawn or
I'll play 97-95 and take your pawn or
I'll play rook a 42 and take this pawn
and I don't see what white does I don't
see any plan for white so by white
pushing all of his pawns on the Kings
side the e4 pawn is weak white can't
play f3 and protect it sort of like what
I did I have a pawn chain this pointy 4
can't be protected so the next two moves
were sort of silly he didn't really do
anything a three which I don't I don't
get I attacked his pawn and now I
thought he was trying to trick me
I thought if I took this pawn which
looks obvious he would play Knight to g4
for a total confusion but when I showed
Knight to g4 he was confused so I guess
that wasn't his plan but yeah now my
bishop is attacked his night somehow
defends is seeing his F pawns I thought
that happened so that was pretty tricky
I thought but there's nothing he can do
to defend his e4 pawn so I might as well
attack it some more Knight to d7 Knight
to c5 now I'm going to take a lot of
pawns now he made the strangest move of
the game and there was a prize for that
so he won the prize for strangest move
of the game King to e3 letting me take
out a 4 with Czech and winning the Jeep
one very suspicious
probably better was something like h3 so
his G pawns defended that I would take
all his other pawns but and I thought
his idea afterward g4 was to play rook
takes e5 I'm sure you were all thinking
of that right and if I take on e5 which
I would not have he takes and Forks my
my king and rook right Alex see exactly
ah and then probably still a draw okay
but I have as missions ugh in between
move Intermezzo right don't take his
rook by the way if I take his Knight and
you'll notice now his knight can't fork
me because it's not on the board anymore
that makes it hard what's its bughouse
then my rook is hanging I hate when that
happens and probably also a draw okay so
what I was going to do was throw in a
check this check is hard to meet because
wherever you move your king I'm going to
play Knight takes bishop let's move the
King here we'll move it somewhere so
blacks a piece ahead can I just took a
piece this piece is attacked twice this
piece is attacked the obvious was for
white are to take my knight okay as
Henny Youngman would say take my knight
please
he was said please right you heard ahead
of Youngman unlike everybody else well
you probably heard him too but everybody
else is like what all right now if King
takes Knight Bishop takes a knight I
think black could win because I have an
extra Bishop plus a better pawn
structure if he takes with a knight he
can't play he can't play Knight takes
and fork because his Knights not there
so I would take his rook and I'm up a
ruck and Justin saw that and decided
that would be good for me because I'm up
a rook so instead of playing Rick takes
pawn which fails tonighti for check he
did not play rook takes pawn and he
played h3 okay and I have many good rook
moves but he would suspect that so I
didn't move my rook
I played naive for Chuck and this is
stronger than moving my rook because now
my rook has access to g3 and when I go
rook g3 is going to be really bad for
him so for example if King to e3 saving
his king I play rook to g3 now we have
some serious pinning an attacking action
going on here that's going to be really
bad for
right if somehow white defends that
which is impossible then I'll still win
this Pont on h3
and then I'll be two pawns ahead
although if you defend that knight on f3
you're a better player than I am because
I'm going to I'm going to take I'm going
to take a lot of things in the next few
moves and as you can see as I promised
last game although I did promise or Oni
would be Karlstad in the Blitz game when
he was like +5 he didn't win but I
promise last game there would be five
isolated pawns this game I promised so
so White's pawn structure is not very
good and after 94 check white resigned
because I'm probably going to be three
or four pawns up on the next four moves
and that was too many pawns for him so
in both games my opponents had bad pawn
structures but in this game my King was
getting in a little trouble that's what
we call double edges play the first game
wasn't double-edged I just had good pawn
structure he had bad pawn structure so
it's just fun for me this game was less
fun because I had a good pawn structure
he had a bad pawn structure but my King
was exposed and he had a leading
development so he could have tried to
punish me better but instead he moved
all of his kingside pawns forward and
didn't really attack my King so those
were played on the same day and I got my
full rating points one rating point for
two wins yes okay the most I could have
hoped for
okay you can't get more than that for
winning two games right Julian who drew
a game and gained 800 points Oh
Oh